but first it's another vast right-wing
conspiracy at least according to the
always honest always truthful always
ethical hillary rodham clinton now today
the two-time presidential loser broke
her silence and announced that the
durham filing which all but accuses her
campaign of oh
you know kind of uh looking in at the
other campaign to say it politely was
fake news
pushed forward by fox really according
to hillary this is just another case of
her enemies trying to smear her sterling
reputation quote trump and fox are
desperately spinning up a fake scandal
to distract from his real ones so it's a
day that ends in a why the more his
misdeeds are exposed the more they lie
don't worry if there's someone you can
really trust to give you it straight
it's hillary clinton right remember the
same hillary who lied about the private
server the same one that lied about
classified material on that private
server the same hillary that lied about
whether she wiped the server clean with
like a cloth the same hillary that lied
about benghazi and about that trip to
bosnia under sniper fire the same
hillary clinton who lied about white
water and her husband's many sexual
transgressions
let's jar your memory shall we
this is
the great story here for anybody willing
to find it and write about it and
explain it is this vast right-wing
conspiracy that has been conspiring
against my husband since the day he
announced for president
right in reality he was never a vast
right-wing conspiracy at all bill did in
fact have sexual relations with that
woman and many other women apparently
hillary knew exactly what was going on
and she chose to lie about that and so
many other things that's because hillary
clinton by the way is a world-renowned
liar or congenital liar as william
sapphire once said now that's what she
does day in and day out and given what
we know ask yourself this question are
you going to trust an official court
filing from a special prosecutor or do
you trust hillary clinton i think the
answer could not be more obvious hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else